We're gonna take a hero
We're gonna take a hero We're gonna take a hero MVP
Hewaha Finally about to depart stood up in the dark Let's
turn a page anew in the storybook Where legends make their
mark Can't stop this rush to my head A cellarando here in my
heart How it rings, everything It's a dazzling and shining
star Let's head together to Electric Town I'll swing on over
with you Oh, what a thrill to be by your side There's
nothing we can't do We bloom and fade and write the rhythm
of the seasons And every time that we make it for a new
start I smile because I'm with you MVP Take off all I need
help We're skylighted Every new, every pink and green and
blue We're sort of legend and new A carabara and a carabara
And you are a part of the world And you're so you're
defending each and every world Let's go We're all Let's go
Let's go, let's go
Painting the future we seek now Don't feel dreaming I think
colors will light the stage Build the world with miracles
MVP Let's go
Let's go And lights ready to feel the beat Voices ready to
shout along Everybody's eyes on me Singing for you I'm your
flower fairy CD Working hard to write happy endings to
everyone's fairy tales And it makes me super duper happy You
watch over me as I bloom and grow Everyone come along with
me I'll see you soon My, my, good How can I serve you?
Would you like food?
Or a bath?
Or maybe a scary story?
Welcome to the arcade!
I'm your yokai princess, Victoria Robot!
You wanna punish it?
Vicky!
Punch!
Oi!
What are you doing?
Give me my head back!
The sky was all clear and it's fog We made this comfy little
world where I'm here with you They would have it almost like
it's magic Come with me and don't step in a fantasy No
matter how long I wonder where our night parade will be
today Real, virtual, welcome to the dance and say MVP MVP
MVP Forever
Colorfully, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Catching all the way to the future,
And we'll be forever Oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh I love
you, love you, love you love you